quel geste
[Musique]
c
et une à deux nuits lave la voiture deux
signaux vidéo matinale
[Musique]
que ça reste aux meubles effet satisfact
et on le met de tout ça mais bien
entendu un pur
en huit groupes d'étudiants tomorrow
dignity en europe
un colloque les matamores de manille
pourtant aucune ville ne sera parfaite
ou facile mais il n'en reste pas moins
que c'est la responsabilité tous
d'entreprendre certain changement et le
changement vient de soi même
m
[Applaudissements]
si on s'adonnait à ça vous êtes tous
venus merci bon ben on va se mettre à
l'aise
il fait bien bon chez vous merci de nous
accueillir je trouve pas je n'attends
que ça fait quand même bizarre d'être
dans cette salle et puis danseront rouge
on n'a pas l'habitude d'avoir des
limites parce que pendant un an on a
quand même vécu dans des décors de fou
comme celui ci ou comme celui là oui et
puis le rythme aussi à ses cadences et
alors qu'on a appris à ralentir on a un
petit peu en mode péruvien des andes à
plus de 5000 mètres d'altitude
hyper lent mais bon on va respecter le
timing un parti c'est promis alors il ne
savait pas que c'était impossible alors
ils l'ont fait comme le disait si mes
remarques twin ben nous on ne savait pas
que c'était impossible alors on l'a fait
on vous le cache pas en quelques mois
mais on a tout quitté tout vendu on a
vendu la maison on a vendu la voiture on
a laissé tomber le contrat de travail à
bas désormais en des han et des nomades
et notre maison c'est le monde avec
toute sa belle diversité qu'on aime tant
bon pourquoi cette grande révolution
dans notre vie ben tout simplement pour
vivre notre rêve et donner plus de sens
à notre vie aussi on voulait voyager on
voulait aller dans des territoires
reculés on voulait rencontrer des gens
positifs des gens en mouvement en
transition qui portent des projets
constructifs pour la planète
on voulait voir tous les beautés toutes
les beautés de ce monde aussi bas alors
on l'a fait alors là vous nous voyez en
train de travailler
mais c'est exactement pour ça qu'on a
pris la route on est partis 375 jour
seul mais paca avec deux caméras un
appareil photo et un drone pour pour
faire un livre pour faire un film un
monde positif pour faire des
documentaires et surtout pour amener un
message positif et on l'espère inspirant
alors donc on est parti comme tu l'as
dit mais partir avec sa collègue ou son
collègue pendant un an ça peut paraître
insurmontable heureusement on est mariés
pascal pascal et ma femme
et il ya quelques années elle a inventé
son métier de rêve à l reporter du monde
positif ma journée je l'attends c'est
mon mari qui est journaliste qui a
travaillé pendant 17 ans à la rtbf la
télévision
big belge est désormais comme vous le
voyez il a balancé le costume
alors ça faisait quelques années qu'on
se disait qu'on avait des métiers
complémentaires que ce serait bien qu'on
fasse des reportages ensemble mais
jonathan il avait vraiment le besoin et
le le désir de s'investir dans sa
carrière ici en belgique est alors à un
moment de voilà je n'ai pas attendu
j'ai pris mon envol tout seul avec mon
appareil photo en bandoulière aux quatre
coins du monde pour faire des reportages
positif voila voila pascal a donc tracé
sa route elle s'est envolée ce qui était
un beau challenge tout de même pour un
couple de vivre plusieurs mois parents
séparés mais on a vécu cette aventure
ensemble et je profite qu elle est pas
là pour vous dire que je trouve qu'elle
a bien raison parce qu'elle est devenue
une belle photographe de portraits pour
pascal la vie est faite de rencontres et
au travers ses photos au travers un
visage parfois des rides
un regard un sourire il ya moyen grâce à
l'appareil photo de transmettre des
histoires de raconter parfois toute une
vie au travers d'un simple visage
faisons l'exercice peut-être avec
quelques clichés regarder
alors pour parler un petit peu de moi
derrière cette carrière qui me semblait
tout tracé pendant des années je me suis
aussi posé pas mal de questions j'ai
sans cesse été en recherche de sens
alors que la personne qui met la plus
proche quelque part ne montrait le
chemin à suivre
comme quoi nos proches nos amis nos
familles ceux qui nous connaissent le
mieux sont parfois le meilleur miroir de
nos rêves intérieure et donc il est bon
d'écouter les messages qu'ils nous
envoient c'est exactement ce que j'ai
fait après un petit temps c'est vrai de
réflexion j'ai eu un long cheminement
personnel et un moment je me suis dit
bah oui mais je vais faire comme elle en
fait moi aussi j'ai envie de voyager moi
aussi j'ai envie de faire des reportages
au bout du monde de voyager au long
cours et alors je me suis dit je vais
organiser un skype avec pascal moi
j'étais un en belgique en brabant wallon
l éther hong kong chacun son mode de vie
manifestement et donc j'ai pris skype et
et je lui ai dit assez fièrement ça y
est j'ai enfin décidé de partir aussi on
va voyager un an et on va tourner des
documentaires et là elle m'a répondu
super ok mal auront 20 la maison voilà
on vend la maison
comme quoi ma femme les femmes en
général ont le don peut-être de nous
pousser nous les hommes toujours un
petit peu plus en dehors de notre zone
de confort et en ce qui nous concerne
c'était une très bonne idée en tout cas
alors là vous nous voyez dans un décor
de fou ben voilà comme on vous l'a dit
on a voulu quitter notre société de
consommation qui pour nous avait trop de
trop trop de contraintes d'attendre de
riz trop de mails trop trop trop
donc on a voulu vraiment se libérer on a
voulu ces purées de ce qui n'était pas
important pour nous on a voulu se
rapprocher de l'essentiel on a voulu
quitter cette autoroute de la vie
quotidienne et toutes nos certitudes
alors quand on a vendu la maison il ya
plus ou moins un an et demi on a fait un
gros tri dans nos affaires et il nous
restait plus ou moins 50 caisses mais
après l'année de voyage qu'on a passé on
a voulu refaire un tri pour se libérer
et encore ces purées désormais une res
20 caisses alors on se dit peut-être au
prochain retour ben il ne restera plus
que dix caisses mais vous le voyez en a
on a vécu avec un sac à dos de 15 kilos
pendant un an avec trois pantalons trois
tee-shirts trois pulls et on se disait
au final que en rigolant qu'on mettait
nos vêtements préférés tous les jours
mais on se rend compte qu'en fait on n'a
pas eu besoin de grand chose
c'était parfait on a manqué de rien en
tout cas on a vécu avec l'essentiel et
c'était très bien comme ça qu'est ce qui
a changé entre ces 50 caisses et ses
vingt caisses en fait rien n'a changé et
en fait tout a changé parce que c'est
notre regard sur les choses qu'on
possède qui s'est tout à coup transformé
après un an de voyages et en rentrant
tout à coup on avait plus besoin de ce
vieux meubles qu'on avait acheté à la
brocante ou de ce service complet qu'on
avait ramené du magasin suédois
non non on voulait on voulait tester le
minimalisme en fait tout ce qu'ils nous
disent dans les livres que la sobriété
heureux ça existe et que quand on se
libère des choses matérielles bas on
gagne en liberté
on a testé et c'est vrai on est toutes
avaient plus besoin de ces quinze
costume bleu marine c'est 30 chemise
blanche qui rencontrait l'armoire on va
pas vous le cacher un nom surtout pour
vivre hors des sentiers battus puisque
hors des sentiers battus c'est un peu le
nom de code qu'on avait donné à notre
aventure qui était à la fois à la fois
professionnel et personnel
professionnellement ben on voulait faire
du journalisme de solutions c'est-à-dire
aller à la rencontre de gens positifs de
gens inspirants qui portent des projets
constructifs pour l'avenir de la planète
et puis partager ça un maximum et c'est
ce qu'on a fait et puis à titre
personnel on voulait aussi sortir des
sentiers battus comme parce qu'elle l'a
dit des sentiers battus de la vie
quotidienne du métro-boulot-dodo des
choses qui se ressemble un petit peu
trop tous les jours quelque part ben en
allant si loin à la rencontre des autres
on voulait aussi un petit peu retourné à
la rencontre de nous mêmes et c'est ce
qu'on a fait alors on avait envie de
vous raconter tout le voyage ce soir
mais en 18 minutes c'était un petit peu
long peut-être où courent les 18 minutes
donc on s'est dit on va choisir juste
quelques mots et quelques images et
résumé un an de voyages plus ou moins
comme ceci
on a traversé la forêt amazonienne le
désert de namib groenland et les
couleurs islandaise on a marché dans le
désert au chili en australie à oman et
sur une rivière gelée en himalaya
on s'est essoufflée dans les andes
péruviennes on a été secoué par une
tempête au groenland et on a respiré
pleinement dans les forêts de sibérie
on a aussi vu de drôle de visage
on a vu des baleines des chameaux des
ours bruns mais qu à la mairie nocera cd
charmant iguane ou galapagos on a roulé
les cheveux au vent en australie en
namibie en islande en norvège et à oman
oui bon enfin home and his past
ça commence bien les sous doués en
vacances pop
on a dépassé le cercle polaire arctique
on a rencontré les belges en colombie en
ethiopie à la réunion en tasmanie et
diable que c'était bien
on a vécu avec peu de chose mais
l'essentiel à cuba en papouasie nouvelle
guinée
oui on a ressenti la douceur de vivre
hawaï australie nouvelle calédonie
vanuatu
on a connu l'extrême pauvreté au
bangladesh en éclats et le bonheur des
buttes années on est passé de 47 degrés
à oman à -35 au zanskar
on a foulé des terres volcaniques à la
réunion au kamtchatka et en islande où
on a rencontré la bonté la beauté on
sait nourrir on se tait mais on a
partagé on a travaillé on a écouté le
silence on a été émis on a rit on a vécu
intensément
rien ne sera jamais plus pareil voilà
après un temps aussi intense
rien ne sera jamais plus pareil ça c'est
clair il ya une petite phrase qui nous a
vraiment accompagner sur le chemin du
voyage sais je sais que je ne sais rien
cette socrates qui a dit ça
manifestement c'était un voyageur parce
que c'est une phrase qui nous a vraiment
fait du bien elle attise la curiosité et
l'humilité dont on a vraiment tous
besoin et dans toutes les rencontres on
s'est dit en fait on a tellement à
apprendre des autres et on s'est
vraiment promis de le répéter tenter
plus ici en europe dans nos sociétés qui
ont quand même toujours tendance à se
considérer un petit peu comme le modèle
de référence dans le monde entier et qui
ont surtout une furieuse tendance pour
le moment pas à se refermer sur elle
même donc on profite de la scène pour le
répéter on a tellement à apprendre des
autres
oui tu parles d eau jonathan on avait
particulièrement envie de vous partager
des rencontres qui nous ont vraiment
beaucoup toucher vraiment marqué pendant
cette année
comme vous le voyez siruna cannes alors
una cannes c'est une femme bangladaises
qui en fait qu'à fonder les ong
friendship en 2002 et c'est une femme
musulmane dans un monde d'hommes qui à
la tête d'une équipe de plus ou moins
1800 personnes et le combat de runa
qu'est née de son ong c'est s'occuper
des chars et chars se sont saisis les
éphémères qui apparaissent et qui
disparaissent au gré des inondations et
qui ont une espérance de vie de plus ou
moins 10 ans et vous dire aussi qu'à
plus ou moins un million de personnes
qui vivent sur sept chars donc c'est un
sacré combat qu'elle mène puis on vous
l'a dit on a rencontré des belges voilà
philippe qui vit là dans sa cabane dans
le nord de la colombie dans la forêt
dans la montagne et philippe il vit en
communauté ils sont 22 25 personnes y
vivent en totale harmonie avec la nature
et puis avec les hommes sur place
puisque ces terres appartiennent depuis
des siècles aux indiens wiwa et tous
ensemble ils ont décidé de vivre en lien
avec la durabilité et la permaculture
avec l'objectif fou de devenir un jour
autosuffisant et le jour où ils
deviendront taux suffisant philippe la
promise rasera cette barbe est alors à
bowie que vous voyez ici dans son champ
de tef alors c'est un chef de village en
ethiopie plus précisément dans la région
du tigré
c'est une région qui est
particulièrement touché par la
sécheresse et la famine et à bohars oui
nous a vraiment impressionnés
parce qu'il a transformé son village en
une véritable petite oasis alors il ya
un autre magnifique bagages congo
ramenez qu'on nous a ramenés c'est les
beautés de la nature partout dans le
monde et la nécessité de la protéger
cette nature alors ça peut paraître
banal de dire ça de nos jours mais nous
dans toutes ces petites communautés on a
rencontré des gens et on a mis des
visages en fait sur ce terme très
abstrait de réchauffement climatique se
tonde ce sont toutes ces personnes qu'on
a rencontrés en papouasie en ethiopie au
bangladesh ce sont toutes ces personnes
au groënland aussi qui sont en fait les
premières victimes et qui sont et qui
seront les premières victimes des grands
des règlements et puis dans d'autres
contrées comme le kamtchatka où la
namibie on a rencontré la nature sauvage
qui vit en toute liberté alors que nous
les hommes sommes derrière des barbelés
pour être protégés dans ces contrées on
a rencontré des hommes qui étaient tous
capables encore de silence et de
contemplation face à cette nature
sauvage et en fait ça nous a quand même
assez bien rassuré sur l'avenir du monde
alors on s'est rendu compte aussi que
c'était beaucoup plus porteur d'avoir un
projet à deux que de passer chacun dix
heures par jour derrière un écran
d'ordinateur
on va pas vous le cacher pendant cette
année on sait pas beaucoup qui tu es
mais on sait jamais autant rapprochés on
s'est jamais autant aimé est en fait
avant ça pourtant on avait le modèle
presque parfait on avait la maison on
avait le boulot on avait la voiture on
avait même le chien mais il nous
manquait quelque chose
il nous manquait étant personnellement
que professionnellement il nous manquait
du sens et quand on s'est rencontré il
ya dix neuf ans on ne rêvait pas quelque
part d'une vie parallèle où chacun avait
le nez dans le guidon
bon on n'est pas en train de vous dire
que nous on a le modèle parfait
la recette du bonheur certainement pas
parce qu'un an de voyages bas c'est des
os et des bas c'est la vie en fait et
c'est des galères aussi par exemple au
bangladesh
on en parlait ça a été dur de vivre un
mois dans ce pays très pauvre très
pollué surpeuplée aussi l'ethiopie
également un grande pauvreté la
mendicité surtout des enfants c'était
vraiment pour nous assez bouleversant et
puis hawaï
on rêvait de voir hawaï on a vu à hawaï
mais il a plu absolument tous les jours
c'est la vie des voyageurs
et puis on a rencontré beaucoup de gens
aussi un des des voyageurs comme nous
mais certains qui vont beaucoup plus
loin qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
aventuriers on a rencontré des citoyens
de ce monde qui sont beaucoup plus
radicaux que nous dans leurs choix mais
on sait pas comparer on s'est dit après
tout ça en fait chacun son everest ce
qui est important c'est que
chacun on se rapproche de cette chalenge
personnes personnels de ses envies de
ses besoins
et c'est sans doute un beau chemin sur
lequel on peut tous avancer avancer vers
soi et versé défi personnel
alors aujourd'hui professionnellement on
n'a plus peur de rien on à l'énergie
pour déplacer des montagnes
on a on éditeurs livre on fait un film
on fait des documentaires et on a envie
de rester nomades et d'ailleurs on va
bientôt repartir sur les routes mais on
se dit qu'en fait une page blanche offre
souvent beaucoup plus de possibilités
pour le futur et que au final vraiment
chacun à écrire sa plus belle page nous
on voulait voir le monde positif en tout
cas on n'est pas naïf on sait très bien
qu'il ya des enjeux incroyable est que
le monde ne va pas très bien mais on
veut surtout continuer à rencontrer des
personnes inspirante des projets
positifs des beautés de la planète
alors on reprendra la route pour ça oui
donc nous aussi au bain on a on a
quelque part pris le chemin de la
transition
et comme le disait si bien gandhi on
essaye d'être le changement qu'on veut
voir dans le monde
en fait on est tous capable de grands
changements on est tous capable de
quitter cette zone de confort surtout
quand on se rend compte comme nous
finalement pas qu'elle ait pas si
confortable
on est tous capables d'entreprendre sa
vie rêvée et en fait on est tous
capables de croire si fort en or n 15
jours ils deviennent réalité et donc si
chacun développe son talent si chacun
développe sa passion pour en faire
bénéficier sa vie personnelle
sa famille sa communauté et si chacun
rayonne de cette passion et de son
talent et trouve merveilleusement bien
sa place dans le monde alors on pense
que la planète n'en sera que plus
positive mais pour vous si tout était
possible
que feriez vous
cher
[Musique]